[Musique]
madame mademoiselle monsieur alors où
commence habituellement le spectacle que
vous attendez où le film vous allez
entendre des candidats et des programmes
et cela pendant quinze jours le grand
nombre de candidats risquent de vous
irriter on a parlé de foire électorale
mais dans de nombreux pays
le rideau de fer communiste est tombé
sur ce spectacle là je m'en vais
demander un effort à chacun et à chacune
d'entre vous quel que soit votre âge
votre profession aux options politiques
votre religion
un effort qui s'appelle la démocratie
celui de m'écouter et d'écouter aussi
les autres celui de distinguer entre des
projets de société et aussi de
distinguer les promesses impossibles car
je dois vous le dire dans un grand pays
moderne comme la france
tout n'est pas possible chacun de nous a
mesuré hier le drame national que
constitue la disparition de georges
pompidou et chacun mesure aujourd'hui
l'enjeu de cette élection présidentielle
choisir la france dans laquelle nous
voulons vivre
c'est un choix décisif c'est un choix de
société
mais pourquoi donc je suis candidat j'ai
été trois fois ministre 11 ans président
de l'assemblée nationale et trois ans
premier ministre depuis 27 ans je suis
maire de bordeaux et je m'en vais vous
faire une confidence je suis très
heureux pourquoi donc me lancer dans
cette bataille parce que de 1969 à 1972
j'ai pu jeter les fondements d'une
nouvelle société plus juste plus libre
plus humaine et parce que depuis 20 mois
j'ai pu réfléchir sur mon action
un paysan abandonnerait-il son champ
réduit labourer un maçon son mur admis
construit et un ouvrier sa pièce et
demie l'usiné de 1969 à 1972
nous avons prouvé ensemble que le
progrès étaient possibles sans
bouleversement que la justice sociale
été possible sans hausse des prix et que
les conflits normaux dans une société
libre pouvait être conclu par le
dialogue et la recherche de l'accord
naturellement ces changements doivent se
faire dans l'ordre
pendant ces quinze jours dans les 47
villes de france que je vais visiter
je préciserai les objectifs et les
moyens de cette nouvelle société que je
vous propose de construire ensemble pour
ce soir je me bornerai à vous indiquer
trois orientations principales de ce
contrat de progrès que je veux passer
avec vous sans discours est sans
concession rétablir une monnaie forte et
des prix stables rétablir l'égalité des
chances dans l'école et dans l'emploi la
france le peut si vous le voulez nous le
ferons
garantir un revenu annuel à toutes
celles familles ou personnes privées qui
ont subi les conséquences fâcheuses de
la perte de l'emploi de la maladie ou de
la disparition d'un proche la france le
peut si vous le voulez nous le ferons
françaises français je vous le répète
tout n'est pas possible je ne vous fais
pas de promesses
je veux passer avec vous un contrat de
progrès j'attends de vous confiance et
fort je suis sûr que vous comprenez la
nécessité d'une discipline économique
dès lors que toutes les couches sociales
sans exception participe à la
répartition des fruits de la croissance
et aussi aux chars françaises français
mon action mon expérience mon énergie
mon enthousiasme je les offre ce soir à
chacun et à chacune de vous pour la
france
[Musique]